today we'd like to explore the idea of
the center of mass or the center of
gravity of a rigid object for instance
take this rod and if I try to balance it
on my finger at a certain point in that
rod I'm balancing it via the
gravitational force and this point is
often referred to as the center of
gravity of the rod now if we were in
empty space with no gravitational field
then the center of gravity doesn't make
any sense but this point still coincides
with what we call the center of mass of
the object and now I'd like to define
center of mass so let's consider our
rigid body and we'll just describe it as
some object we'll make it idealized and
that there's going to be trying to find
some point in this object and we'll
identify that point as the center of
mass now let's imagine that this rigid
body is made up of a bunch of little
pieces so we have MJ and this Jade piece
is located from the center of mass a
vector R cm now what we want to do how
we want to define this particular point
is that when we make the sum from J
equals 1 to N over every single point in
this body then that will be 0 and this
will be the definition of the center of
mass that when you add up the position
vector with respect to this point
weighted by the mass and you add up all
of those vectors you'll get zero now if
you don't know where the center of mass
is then this is difficult to calculate
so let's find a way where you choose an
arbitrary point and let's write that
arbitrary point say over here we'll
write it like this
s and we'll treat that as our origin and
I'll draw a vector R s J and here I'll
draw the vector R cm
and now what we have from our vector
relationship is that the vector r SJ
equals the vector r cm and that's what I
want to find plus the vector R CM J and
now let's add up multiply each of these
by the mass and make a sound
so we have M J our SJ equals the sum of
M J now the vector R cm this vector no
matter where we picked a point in this
object this vector is always the same
and that's why I pulled it out of the
sum and over here I have the sum from J
goes from 1 to n J 1 to N of MJ r CN J
now recall this is precisely how we
define the center of mass point that
this is zero and so we can now conclude
that the center of mass so you pick an
arbitrary point and if you want to find
that vector to the center of mass what
you do is you make the sum from J goes
from 1 to N of MJ or SJ and you divide
that by J goes from 1 to end MJ and this
is what we call the center of mass so
conceptually the center of mass is the
point in the object where if you take a
vector to any of a little mass elements
and you weight it by the mass element
and you add them up you get 0 if you
wanted to calculate the center of mass
about any point you choose a point as
you draw the vector from s to the object
you sum up those vectors we see by our
vector triangle rule that we can now
calculate that center of mass vector by
this equation and now let's just rewrite
this because this is the total mass and
what we see is that our cm
equals J goes from 1 to n MJ our SJ
divided by the total mass